c'est le candidat debout la france pour
les élections législative partielle dans
la 12e circonscription des yvelines
olivier galland habitants de saint cyr
l'école se lance dans le scrutin
ce père de quatre enfants vit dans la
commune depuis une quinzaine d'années
j'ai commencé à m'impliquer dans la vie
collective avec les associations de
parents d'élèves ça fait 12 ans que je
suis tête de liste sur l'école du
quartier engagé récemment en politique
avec des convictions proche de celle de
nicolas dupont aignan olivier galland
rejoint en 2010 est le mouvement debout
la france il devient délégué de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines avant
d'être désigné candidat pour la
prochaine élection sur ce territoire
on entend les gens quand on quand on va
à leur contact nous dire je ne vote plus
je ne crois plus en la politique
moi je crois le contraire je crois qu'il
faut se battre il faut se battre pour
nos idées pour défendre nos idées pour
présenter nos idées concernant son
programme olivier galon va engager sa
campagne sur trois axes l'autorité de
l'état la lutte contre les trafics de
drogue et la justice sociale on peut
envoyer massivement les forces de
l'ordre dans les quartiers qui en ont
besoin
et derrière il faut que la justice donne
un exemple fort en mettant de réelles
punition de réelles sanctions afin de
dissuader les délinquants de d'agir une
politique sociale avec avec des crèches
pour les personnes qui en ont besoin
avec des logements pour les couples qui
vont avoir des enfants passent à lui dix
candidats sont en lice les électeurs
sont appelés aux urnes pour le premier
tour le dimanche 20 septembre prochain